[Musik]
hey lieben heute kommt ein ganz
besonderes video denn ganz ganz viele
von euch haben über das jahr 2019 hinweg
gefragt kiki was benutzt du für eine
küchenmaschine euch ist wahrscheinlich
aufgefallen dass ich diese hier wird
anfang des jahres testet und ich habe
mir jetzt meine meinung gebildet und
kann euch ausgiebig darüber informieren
was für vorteile sie bringen das hier
ist die saic repos und ich habe sie
jetzt wirklich seit einem jahr in
gebrauch in den videos aber auch
außerhalb der videos und was ich
vorneweg sagen kann
für mich war es wichtig eine
küchenmaschine zu haben die leise ist
aber leistungsstark und das haben wir
hier zu 100 prozent erfüllt was mir
persönlich jetzt noch ganz ganz wichtig
ist bevor ich hier zu diesem facts
übergehe und euch erklären warum die
maschine gut ist oder warum auch nicht
das erfahrt ihr dann am ende des videos
möchte ich euch noch sagen dieses video
ist nicht gesponsert es ist alles selbst
bezahlt und ich erhalte für keine meiner
aktionen werbegeld von der firma said no
dass ihr das im voraus ist und jetzt
gehen wir mal über zu den fakten was
kann sie wie sind so diese eckdaten die
zahlen das gucken uns jetzt einmal an
[Musik]
eine küchenmaschine hat sang hafte 1200
watt und was mir persönlich aber ganz
ganz wichtig ist dass der motor nicht
überhitzt der motor ist ein drehmoment
starker motor der hier in verbaut ist
und ich merke dass vor allem wenn ich
zum beispiel teile also vor allem
schwere sachen mixer oder wenn ich sehr
sehr lange mix ich gerne an meine kräfte
rezept da habe ich gern zu 96 g kräfte
in der maschine geknetet weil ich
einfach keine lust hatte das ganze zwei
mal zu kneten und zweimal 20 minuten an
zu kneten ich glaube auch das würde das
schaffen aber einmal 20 minuten die
ganze küste masse die hat er gepackt und
das war für mich der moment wo ich
dachte danke schön dass du mir die
arbeit erleichtert und noch ein zusatz
die bag in box besitzt eine load sensing
technologie das heißt falls immer
schwerer back oder rührt teilgehabt
erkennt sie dass automatisch an und
passt die geschwindigkeit so an dass sie
immer in der gleichen notwendigen
geschwindigkeit rührt
außerdem hat die maschine ein
motorschutz system was genau bedeutet
dass falls ihr jetzt was er wirklich
passieren kann
einmal viel viel länger schlägt als
vorgegeben und die maschine läuft und
läuft und läuft dann könnt ihr das ja
wenn bei kleingeräten wirklich mal der
motor überhitzt und dann läuft die
maschine gar nicht mehr er müsse zur
reparatur geben einfach nur unnötiger
stress das motorschutz system ist
einfach daher sinnvoll dass es wirklich
aufhört zu rühren wenn es merkt gleich
könnte der motor durchbrennen ich höre
jetzt lieber auf und kühle etwas ab und
das tolle ist nicht nur dass eben ihr
dieses motto schutzsystem habt ihr habt
zusätzlich noch eine verlängerte
garantie das heißt fünf jahre garantie
auf den motor was ich persönliche
richtig cool fand das ist doch echt das
erste was mir ins auge gestochen ist als
sich die maschine gekauft habe ist der
timer ich liebe den timer weil manchmal
ist echt so ich muss eine masse acht
minuten schlagen oder eine mutter masse
12 minuten und dann habe ich den timer
muss man nicht extra auf dem handy den
timer stellen oder immer wieder auf die
uhrzeit achten sondern kann hier
wirklich auf acht minuten zum beispiel
also ich drücke einfach die pfeiltaste
die auf acht minuten hoch macht die
maschine an und dann geht sie auch echte
von alleine aus machten ganz klein blieb
und dann weil sie ja ok ich muss wieder
zur maschine und die nächste zutat rein
tun
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das was wir immer benötigen wenn die
maschine in gebrauch ist ist der
geschwindigkeitsregler hier habt ihr
einmal den off knopf dann ist die
maschine ganz einfach nicht in betrieb
aber schon an
dann haben wir den pause knopf dann geht
auch schon das lichtlein an das ist auch
so ein cooles gimmick was ihr noch
zusätzlich habt ein licht dann könnt ihr
eure tage besser sehen in der küche
nicht so stark beleuchtet ist und könnte
genau sehen wie ihr teig bzw
früher machte gerade aussieht und dann
unterscheiden wir zwischen 12
geschwindigkeitsstufen ihr braucht je
nachdem was ihr macht eine andere
geschwindigkeit stufe macht jetzt zum
beispiel ashley dann nimmt er die
höchste oder macht ihr nur ein teil
hefeteig der nimmt der geschwindigkeit
stufe 1 bis 3 und so hat eben jedes
rezept seine eigene stufe kommen wir
noch mal kurz zur pause funktion die
finde ich persönlich deshalb so wichtig
weil ihr vor allem wenn ihr zum beispiel
back anfänger seien aber auch bei
fortgeschrittenen die zeit nicht mehr im
blick gehabt und denken oh mein gott wie
lange habe ich jetzt diese eier
geschlagen sind sie jetzt schon flüssig
genug dann seht ihr hier ganz genau wie
viel minuten es sind geht auf pause und
nicht auf auf pause denn dann wird die
zeit gestoppt also angehalten und wenn
ihr dann die weitere zutat hinzufügt und
weiter dreht dann geht die zahl wieder
ganz normal hoch und nimmt seinen lauf
und geht eben nicht auf null und was ich
zum beispiel manchmal denke ich mir
jetzt keine mutter aber bei müttern die
zum beispiel das baby gerade füttern und
denken wie lange hat jetzt schon
geschlagen dann stets alles hier drauf
ihr müsst euch nicht noch sachen dem
hinterkopf märkten die maschine erledigt
das für euch
kommen wir jetzt von den
geschwindigkeitsstufen einmal zum
gehäuse dass sie ist keineswegs plastik
sondern massives drucke kosmos metall
also hochwertiges edelstahl und hier am
motor kopf haben wir tatsächlich auch
schon den entwicklungs knopf das heißt
ihr drückt aber ich mache es gerne in
meiner hand und dann könnt ihr die
maschine anheben und hier kommen dann
die knet einsätze rein was ich euch
jetzt noch sagen kann er informationen
was für mich ziemlich wichtig ist wenn
ich sie zum beispiel verschenke an meine
mutter oder wenn ihr sie an die
großmutter verschenkt die maschine ist
fertig und schwer dementsprechend ist es
ja kein plastik aber eben dass man sie
mit einem handgriff auf und zu bekommt
finde ich persönlich ist sehr sehr
wichtig gerade für ältere menschen die
an eben nicht so viel kraft haben
und falls sie dann doch noch ein
bisschen hilfe und unterstützung
brauchen einfach hier oben den griff
anfassen und dann kann man so auch ganz
einfach die maschinen bedienen und kippt
nicht gleich mit dem ganzen körper nach
vorne und nach hinten
[Musik]
jetzt kommen wir aber mal zu den
zubehörteilen der boss und zwar ist wohl
das allerwichtigste der schneebesen
aufsatz den benutze ich persönlich auch
am allermeisten tatsächlich und den gibt
jetzt einfach so rein und das ist halt
sehr gut geeignet für baiser maßen für
rührt teige die besonders luftig sein
sollen und das geniale ist dass wir hier
einen planeten rührwerk haben das heißt
ähnlich wie bei konditoreien oder
professionellen patisserie dreht sich
hier das früher element im und das
rührwerk gegen den uhrzeigersinn
also wird der ganze inhalt der gesamten
schüssel gepackt hier haben wir jetzt
den knethaken und den verwendet ihr am
allerbesten für hefe tage wenn ihr mal
wieder brot backen möchte und dann am
besten auch eine der niedrigen stufen
verwenden das ist für hefeteig in am
allerbesten den röhr haken am
allerbesten für schwere teige wie zum
beispiel schwere kuchen tage verwenden
wo die eier nicht separat aufgeschlagen
werden ihr könnt ihr mit auch wunderbar
kartoffelpüree zum beispiel machen also
will ich alles was sehr sehr schwer ist
das hier ist eines meiner persönlichen
highlights wenn ich ganz ehrlich bin
dass wir wenn ich genau so oft wie den
schneebesen aufsatz und zwar ist das der
röhr haken mit gummilippe und das
besondere daran ist ihr kennt mich ja
mittlerweile manchmal sage ich ja hebt
zb die biomasse mit ganz viel liebe und
einem teig darunter
und das ist eben genau das dass ich
meine das ist euer teigs aber mit ganz
viel liebe
er setzt ihn einfach auf und will die wm
asse unter hebt dann ganz einfach
einfügen und ganz langsam rühren und die
gummilippe sorgt dafür dass sie alles
vom rand auch einholt und nichts
irgendwie am rand kleben bleibt das
gleiche problem habt ihr bei butter wenn
ich sage butter aufschlagen und ihr
fangt zb mit eurer alten küchenmaschine
an zu schlagen und ihr merkt okay es ist
butter am rand die wird gar nicht
verarbeitet die butter in der mitte ist
schon ganz hell cremig und die am rand
außen immer noch so gelblich und dann
nimmt die reben immer den ruhr haken mit
der schönen gummilippe
[Musik]
im lieferumfang sind übrigens zwei
schüsseln enthaltenen ich finde zwei
schüsseln auch immer ganz wichtig denn
manchmal braucht der eine für eine
baiser masse also zum eiweiß aufschlagen
und müsste dann direkt in den anderen
schlüssel weitermachen daher perfekt das
s2 sind sie haben wir einmal eine
glasschüssel das borosilikatglas das
heißt ihr könnt sie in die spülmaschine
tun in die mikrowelle 4,7 liter
fassungsvermögen also mega top darauf
achte ich nämlich auch immer sehr und
was ihr auch noch habt ist eine
edelstahl schüsse könnt ihr auch eine
spülmaschine geben für die einfache
reinigung das sind 3,8 liter
fassungsvermögen
ihr bekommt zusätzlich ein spritzschutz
mitgeliefert das heißt er dient nicht
nur als spritzschutz sondern auch als
ein gis hilfe oder ein schritt hilfe
falls immer zucker oder mehl einfach
hier über die öffnung wieder zugeben
möchte der passt sowohl auf die
glasschüssel als auch auf die edelstahl
schüsse
ein letztes zubehörteil möchte ich euch
jetzt präsentieren und zwar ist dass der
deckel vermutlich für euch nur ein
gewöhnlicher deckel für mich aber sehr
hilfreich wenn ihr zum beispiel hilfe
geknetet deckel drauf machen und direkt
in der schüssel ruhen lassen und ihr
könnt den deckel auch gerne auf die
innenstadt schüssel geben das heißt auch
wie beim prinzip vorher mit dem
spritzschutz passt der deckel auf beide
schüsseln und das geniale ist ihr
bekommt im set wirklich alle beide
schlüsseln also nicht wie man es kennt
das man nur einen schlüssel bekommen und
sich die andere extra dazu bestellen
muss sondern es ist alles schon das was
ihr heute in diesem video gesehen habt
im paket mit dabei für mich noch mal ein
riesen pluspunkt beide schüssel sowie
diese drei elemente sind komplett
spülmaschinengeeignet beim schneebesen
aufsatz rate ich euch spürt sie mit der
hand damit ihr auch wirklich die
langlebigkeit habt für mich war das
allerletzte ko-kriterium die lautstärke
denn ich hatte vorher eine
küchenmaschine die war extrem laut wenn
sie auf der höchsten stufe war teilweise
auch auf den stufen runter und ich
konnte mich in einem raum nicht mit
hamza unterhalten also ich konnte mich
bei meinen mann
wenn dem gleichen raum an und die
maschine einfach mal die eier schlägt
nicht unterhalten und wir mussten uns
anschreien und das ist eben bei dieser
maschine nicht der fall
die ist deutlich leiser auch auf der
höchsten stufe und mit einer deutlich
besseren meiner meinung nach einer
deutlich besseren leistungsstärke und
jetzt möchte ich euch noch etwas sagen
was mir persönlich sehr am herzen liegt
denn ihr wisst ja dass auf meinen
schultern so ein bisschen der druck
lastet das wenn ich was zeige der
zuschauer gleich denkt okay das produkt
ist gut genutzt das also ist dieses
produkt gut daher habe ich euch jetzt
ein jahr lang hingehalten und konnte
euch ein jahr lang keine fragen
beantworten zu was ist das für eine
küchenmaschine ist die gut bist du
zufrieden wie heißt sie ich will sie
unbedingt bestellen daher verzeiht sie
mir dass ich euch jetzt ein bisschen
hingehalten habe im endeffekt muss ich
sagen die maschine ist top auch was
preis leistung angeht was die power
angeht die lautstärke die zubehörteile
ihr könnt sie gerne bei mir im shop
erwerben wir kommen auch schon zum
nächsten teil
für mich ist es so wenn ich was in
meinem shop aufnehme dann muss es auch
wirklich eine top qualität haben und es
muss auch sein geld wert sein
ich habe die küchenmaschine im shop
aufgenommen stehe dafür meine
gesicht das heißt wenn sie irgendwie in
irgendeiner form schlecht wäre dann
fällt ist alles auf mich zurück und
deshalb könnt ihr euch sicher sein
diese maschine ist wirklich sehr sehr
sehr empfehlenswert so und jetzt möchte
ich euch so langsam verabschieden
ich bin dankbar dafür dass ihr bis
hierhin geschaut hat und wenn ihr weiter
fragen habt kommentare schreibt nur noch
gerne hier drunter können uns auch gerne
austauschen
setzt euch den link zur maschine auch in
die infobox und ansonsten sehen wir uns
bei meinem nächsten videos eure ki
[Musik]